[Musique]
mais foutez moi la paix je me demande où
vous allez vous allez me sall up
flash - la grande tortue votto a laissé
tomber ses parents en braille
voyant [ __ ] les voyants c'est le bus
pendant donc c'est le 51 ici non c'est
pas sans compter ainsi monsieur je suis
aveugle il faut que je prenne moins chez
prioritaires j'ai une carte de priorité
messieurs pendant cette qualité c'est
pas en cause assure non non vous allez
vous parle affolait fera [ __ ] je
jouais là-bas et puis taxi taxi avec
soon on est où là
vous voulez on va chez vous alors
d'avoir huawei
on va chez vous pourquoi ça vous êtes de
passage à paris
voilà ça vous dirait d'avoir une
expérience avec un non voyant pourquoi
pas mais j'ai pas beaucoup de temps aux
missions et la petite jeune tu viens
elle a dit jonathan bien à l'hôtel
pendant longtemps pour moi faisait moins
pas de chasse merci je me sers vouzan
vous prenez l'autobus et vous descendez
place de l'opéra le 14 à 21
n'importe quel jeu on soude et j'aime
bien avoir touché à faire bâtir près sûr
non non non non mais je vais y aller non
je peux y aller
merci madame ah bon ya pas de moto là ya
pas une honda dominator ya rien là on
m'a piqué ma bécane mer mais moi je vais
rentrer chez moi
je dispose qu'est-ce qui se passe qui
c'est qui c'est quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qu'il ya monique monique je
suis pas à ce qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est qui
bon là qu'est ce qui se passe c'est bon
tu sais votre cul ça rend chez vote que
monsieur boniface les verts un boum boum
quand sévère ou nous dit quand le feu
est vert tient debout voulait traverser
avant sa stricte le hockey
le ou vers le banc louvre où opèrent à
la matra métro louvre ya bien
opéra c'est rouge là rien et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux